As the global music market shifts from a tangible product to a digital one,...
...the very nature of what the industry sells is changing.
With so much content instantly accessible across the world...
...acts succeed not by selling music but by selling sensation.
A product that readily crosses language and cultural barriers.
The cold, hard reality right now is music is actually no longer the business.
If anything, it's become a business card.
If it becomes popular, it leads to other opportunities.
That is where they make money.
I think if you're working in music, if you're a group,...
...then it's really creating your brand is your core and...
...with Korean society, I think branding of their groups,...
...that's one thing that you really, really wanna win, really much better than probably most people.
I think that's what the Americans used to do well.
It really harks back to the Madonna, Michael Jackson days of...
...superhero pop performance. That's what sort of...
...gets people talking in an age with chatter is the main currency. Then,...
...that's what you've gotta do.
The second wave of Korean music has taken a prominent global position.
Thanks to social media.
How long this wave lasts will depend entirely on how those artists and taste - makers...
...continue to adopt the mercurial winds of technology and culture.
In Seoul for Monocle, I'm Jonathan Openshaw.